boom
super pump let's do it boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake and really excited to be
talking about thoughts on Takashi six
nine so he is known as a rainbow themed
rapper and internet personality he is
quite the nuanced person to have a
discussion about so I'm really looking
forward to talking about it with
everyone and there's a lot to unpack and
I have notes I have imagery for us to
look at as we go through this
that's his famous rainbow themed hair
and grill that he's wearing on his teeth
and also clothing and whatnot and
there's a lot to unpack about him I have
a lot of notes to talk about and you can
look at the link also in the bio to his
Breakfast Club interview he's had two of
them and also another interview on the
Angie Martinez show where he unpacks the
reason why he's name is six-nine which
will actually get to in more detail with
you will we'll go over that together so
there's there's a lot to talk about and
I want to start off by just explaining
why this is such a importantly nuanced
topic this is not by the way how awesome
is the waterfall today right there it's
awesome
nature epic so this is extremely
important for us the unpacking it's
nuanced because 6:9 is not binary he's
not a black or white kind of a person to
just either say he's absolutely
incredible or he's absolutely horrible
I'm just like everyone really is is
really important I guess unpack
everyone's soul in all of their nuanced
and so I think a really good place to
start with him is that you know why did
he pick six nine well he jokes about it
and he says that it's because he's
really good at sixty-nining which is
very funny but then he also has this
really interesting way of explaining it
and here on the Angie Martinez show she
asked him so a couple months ago why and
you know he wrote there you see the
number he wrote the number six and he
showed it to her and then he persists
and then he and then he then he asked
her what do you see and she said I see
six and he said well I see nine and then
he flipped it around and he showed it to
her again and obviously when you flip it
around again the number says nine to the
other person it says sixty you and so
the reason why he he keep he says that
this is why he came up with the name is
because of the importance of perspective
and I thought damn for for a young you
know twenty two-year-old and especially
the one that grew up with the
circumstances that he did he sure didn't
manage to come up with something quite
interesting as a name for himself with
the new number numero numeric character
six and nine and how that relates to
perspective and he references frequently
what it's like to to be poor and needing
to feed yourself or your family or to
provide yourself with shelter or
clothing and when other people just
straight up just think that you are like
a bad human being for needing to go what
into to do things that are
unconventional in order to survive and I
don't think that that's necessarily fair
because they're not fully accepting
their perspective she made it clear to
and she'd come into my shoes to
understand who I am and why I feel this
way and
I thought that was really interesting so
you know let's I mean let's talk about
this like you know I'm I'm trying to
bring up like you know his shoes his
perspective you know who is this guy
well his birth name was Daniel Hernandez
and he is 22 right now and he's been
involved in you know I'm trying to learn
as much about this as possible but he's
had some you know some some run-ins with
with the law and he has been cutting it
really close with the law and creating a
lot of beef with other people and I'll
get into unpacking the nuance of this
but beef equals views to many people and
this is this is not the first time that
people down in you know Los Angeles or
in New York understand that you can
actually use the media's machinery to
cast beef on to other people or to make
purposeful media propaganda that will
then get you more views get you more
attention and so this isn't the first
time that we're seeing people take
advantage of this process so always
important to keep in mind that people
can use the media in that sense I think
he has been doing that quite a bit for
himself
he said I'm a product of my society and
so let's talk about his upbringing and
he's been he's been quite a bit probed
on these interview shows about about you
know why he says that he's the king of
New York or why he says that why he
tells people that they should suck his
dick or why he says that these these
different sort of controversies that are
being brought up about his behavior and
I think it's I think that's of course
there's a place for that but I think
there's a huge huge missed opportunity
and that missed opportunity is because
we are not asking 6:9 about what his
thoughts are on humanity and where he
would like to see humanity go like how
he would like to design humanity moving
forward into the future what would be
his ideal societal design so I think
asking him those types of questions is
really important and
6:9 open invitation to come on to our
show and talk to us about the nuance
behind your worldview in your world
perspective you can see how playful he
is it's very strange you watch one of
his one of his videos and you'll see his
him in his videos maybe being a little
bit you know aggressive and whatnot but
then you see him in his interviews and
he's super playful and friendly and kind
and in in some ways and and and you know
you can tell that that that's a very
thing to not be so scared of so all
right let's talk about his upbringing so
this is interesting born in in in
Brooklyn and his his his his father well
his father what initially his biological
father wasn't around and then his he had
a he had his his actual his father then
after his biological father left his
father was shot and killed I believe a
block from his house and that was when
6:9 was 13 years old and so his mom was
left to raise him and his brother and
you know she came from Mexico with
nothing and so when I when I really
think about him and I think about where
he came from with that you know that
PTSD which he does talk about the stress
that comes from you know being 13 and
having your father who was an important
figure in his life and does it die a
block from his house get shot that kind
of stuff takes a toll on you and so that
emotional emotional disturbing feeling
that he had throughout his life caused
him to also act out and eventually get
expelled from school in eighth grade for
bad behavior and he got a girl pregnant
when he was 17 and he calls her his baby
mama and with a you know that with that
daughter on the way he got into a
predicament
that predicament was was it was a little
bit it's it's strange because there
there's you know Shar million was China
on Breakfast Club was trying to point
that at him and say like aren't you a
rapist and you know this controversy
that 69 got into was not rape whatsoever
at least through him speaking about it
and through the through the reports that
were written about it
he was with someone that was underage he
was 17 and she was 13 I believe and what
happened was that she was with him and
and and doing some sort of dancing
activities while she had some of her
clothing off and so that was a very big
issue and that's a four year age gap and
obviously that's an issue you know if
the girl was 17 and the boy was 13 you
know what kind of an issue would arise
if if it's a thirty year old man with a
Ford 14 year old girl or a thirty year
old woman with a fourteen-year-old boy
you know that's a bigger age gap that's
a bigger issue but this is a four year
age gap between what would be like a
senior in high school and a freshman in
high school so you know he was he said
that he was being unfairly treated by
the media which I see that as the
mainstream media is really under fire
right now because they are losing a lot
of their viewership and subscribership
and they're trying to in many ways
clickbait and put unjust lis written
pieces out in some ways and some sources
do that and I can see how that can be
portrayed as a monster but I also you
know don't defend that necessarily that
it's important for us to teach kids that
like hey you know you got to be really
careful with with with when you are a
senior hanging out with a freshman and
that kind of stuff you have to be very
very careful of that kind of stuff and
so
there's a lot of susceptibility to young
minds and so that kind of also catalyzed
the significant law infringement for him
where they were throwing around numbers
like that he was going to be sentenced
for 15 years and he didn't have a lawyer
he had less than a thousand bucks and so
it was really tough for him to have kind
of come come with a realization that hey
like I have to get through this I have
to I have to plead guilty because I
don't have anything to fight against
this and and it's better for me to just
plead guilty and and I get on probation
or do what I need to do as a young kid
and so he did and he ended up because he
had a daughter on the way so he ended up
moving on past that and so I think this
is really important because you you know
6:9 talks about this absolutely insane
system that we live in he says he's a
product of the society that he was born
from and so if you think about it
there's you know there was another
incident here with the product of the
system the his name was kalief Browder
and kalief Browder had a a very very
interesting story kalief Browder was
accused of stealing a backpack this was
in New York City and I believe this was
about eight years ago or so and he was
incarcerated for three years for
stealing a backpack and this is the kind
of stuff that's crazy
and so after he was incarcerated for
three years there were two years of
those three years worth solitary
confinement and and this was for being
accused of stealing a backpack he ended
up going and you know after he got out
of jail after three years he ended up
committing suicide he tried to commit
suicide inside he got this was at Rikers
is the prison in in New York
and he ended up you know writing about
it and talking about how just absolutely
insane that experience was for him and
how this is now happening more and more
across the world and it's very unjust
for young people to go through a process
like that and so I think that that that
system that they're speaking of is very
unjust in many ways and it's important
to correct that unjustness it's
extremely difficult to talk about the
subjects very nuanced and delicate and
close to people's souls and so when you
get this close to people's souls and
hearts and spirits you know it's tough
to talk about in all of its nuance and
thank you for being here and talking to
us here about it so just to you know to
continue moving moving forward there you
know he's you know he's frequently
talking about the difference between
doing something for fun or doing
something as a job and when you do
something for fun you doesn't even feel
like a job so that means that he's he's
he's able to do fun things that he wakes
up every day and he gets to be himself
even though he it can be participate in
some things that may be deemed as as you
know as stupid like saying things like
you know suck my dick to people or
creating so much beef with people or
doing things that are violent or with
weapons and or dealing with drugs and
doing that kind of stuff can get you
into trouble quickly and it's you know
and that's why there was a statement
from the NYPD that we'll get to in a bit
which is why he's currently in the
process of of potentially being locked
up for a long time and that is it's a
little sad because he's got some
interesting messaging that I think is
important for the world to hear but also
it can be important to make sure that
young people are not being involved in
these types of serious behaviors that
can that can put other people's law
at risk and whatnot it's very
complicated because you know in an ideal
you know utopic world there may not meet
there may be some more sort of communal
living in communal processing and more
peace and love and harmony across the
world and less of the authoritarian
forces and more of the sort of just uh
more understanding and I don't know I
don't know how that would evolve with
with violence and gangs and drugs and
guns and stuff like that and it's tough
it's really tough to unpack the NYPD
statement said we actually tried to warn
him but he refused to listen his crew
should have shielded him from being
involved in any crime because he was
their chance to get out Takashi's arrest
hurts the whole crew when you get
involved in shootings in NYC it's an
express ticket to prison and that was
from Ebro in the morning and he got a
statement from his source at NYPD and
that that that beef that he was creating
in NYC was really extremely it was good
for his likes and his views and the
media spotlight but it was really bad
for for him to get locked up and and so
and he wasn't listening to people that
were trying to help him but other people
weren't really getting who he was and
what he was trying to express because if
you can get a whole society you can get
civilization to calm down a little bit
and not care so much about the words
suck my dick just like their [ __ ]
words and that's it that that you can
potentially transition a whole
generation of people from being very
butthurt and upset by those words to
potentially not caring so much about
those words and living their lives with
more of it just be yourself doesn't you
know be yourself and but there are
people that actually get upset by those
words and and it's important to also
respect them and whatnot so it's again
it's extremely
CompTIA extremely nuanced so so you know
that that NYPD stamens interesting
because he had the potential to
potentially be this really powerful
source for his his his crew to kind of
get more further away from the violence
I'm really happy that he made a
distinction between fun and job because
when you're waking up in the morning
doing something you're loved it's fun
and it doesn't feel like work and that's
really really important so he's he's
acting like this major troll and whatnot
at times to people creating this beef
but he's also donated lots of money to
his community in Brooklyn again this is
a supposed thing that he has said
shout out by the way who will teach
robots ethics it's one of our mugs you
can check it out on our website
simulation series comm so we asked these
powerful questions join us and asking
these questions so he has done he's
reported himself that he's done
extremely charitable work in his local
neighborhoods he said that in Brooklyn
he's given away million dollars and you
know earlier in his about when he did
the first Breakfast Club interview he
said that he had given away a couple
tens of thousands of dollars his
community and he would just go and just
talk to random kids on the on the
streets and he wouldn't be like through
a foundation it would just be giving
people money and he would be they said
that he was humble and that he said that
in the recent Breakfast Club interview
about a week ago he said that it was on
November 16th that he had been had to
given a million dollars in donations to
people to support the neighborhood and I
think that's very interesting that he
has he is already giving so much in
philanthropy if that's really the case
that that's that's that's really
interesting that that is him that is who
he is and that he's choosing to do that
and so maybe he was actually on the
right track to helping move the ball
forward with the youth in some ways and
so you know I always challenge us to
think about that so his I mean he keeps
talking about this like sense of you
know of God for himself that he's like
he is the king of New York that he is
you know his number streaming numbers
are nuts which apparently they
absolutely are nuts and that he is just
experiencing tremendous success and that
he had a period of time where you know
the most recently where he you know he
fired all of his promoters I think this
is extremely important on pack because
there's you know we act as promoters at
simulation because we do life events
with prominent figures and when we do
that it's very difficult to negotiate
the right terms with the
speakers because is it depends on when
when their how prominent they are when
they're blowing up if they're getting an
honorarium or a percentage of profit
there's so much nuance that actually
goes into it but one thing that you
never get a second chance at is your
word and not never but that that you
that you have to act like you don't get
a second chance at is your word you have
to have to have to be integrity high
high levels of integrity and love and
honesty towards the people you're
working with and so what
6:9 discovered was that he was actually
not getting much integrity from the
people that he was working with and it's
through things like this that his rate
first shows was 100k and that he was
getting 60 K from his promoters and so
he he called and cancelled the the
performance and then he ended up getting
a feedback from the booking from the
people that were actually booking him
saying that hey we've already paid you
180 K which means that they were paying
him 180 K and that his promoters were
only paying him 60 K so they worth they
were actually getting a a they were they
were ripping him off quite significantly
and you know there's a there's a further
convo with these booking people were
they swear they said that hey like 69
we've paid you 3.6 million dollars
for 15 dates and 69 was only told by his
promoters that he was getting up six
hundred thousand dollars for those 15
dates so he was really pissed off that
they were pocketing three million bucks
and that is absolutely absurd that this
whole process of like who do you trust
and how do you how do you trust them
like look at that pocketing three
million bucks like where's their respect
for him and what he's bringing to the
community what he's trying to give back
to the community and you know he's
multiple times said that he's brings
insane energy to his stages and I
haven't been yet but that that that's
very it's very nuts that they also did
some extortion towards him that they
threatened to leak some stuff a personal
stuff about him too
TMZ and that he said that the worst
thing is jealousy and that there's a
bunch of dirty players out there and you
gotta figure out who those dirty players
are and surround yourself with clean
players and really try your best to do
it he's had some interesting advice
about that and he said that you know
he's signed right now to the Universal
Music Group UMG and Lucian Elliott
Elliott Grange his Aleutians son is his
his his manager his agent and that he's
fired everyone else and that he says
that he fears God in the FBI most so he
had this crazy story of him being of him
being you know kidnapped as well where
where you know he every time he walks
out of his house he's walking out of his
house with a you know head down no one
knows that he's there and his crews
really good at protecting him and
whatnot so no one knows that he's there
and then he got yeah he got hit by
another car and then he got then he
noticed he was being he was being robbed
and he went and led them to his house to
get this so they could have a jewelry
was hoping the nobody got injured then
he rolled out of the car on their way
out and he ended up being um went to the
hospital check to his family everything
was okay after that but there are these
crazy stories like that where he also is
an unsure on who to trust on the inside
of his of his group as well it's just
very very crazy things now he has very
extreme security he took a video of him
like breakdancing in a circle with his
security and the security was it was
quite well equipped you know
xxx tent tent ASEAN or just X is a very
it was a good friend of his in X past
this year and X was very interesting
young man as I as I think 69 is also an
interesting young man and what I think's
really interesting about them is that
they are very eccentric and they're
trying to communicate messages
of potentially harmonizing in different
ways that we have yet to really
understand or experience and and I think
that that that's interesting and that it
shouldn't go we shouldn't just push that
away as something that that that their
messages have these faults and that
because of those little tiny because of
these tiny faults that we shouldn't pay
attention to their messages no we should
totally pay attention to their messages
and take these really powerful
statements from them they're young and
they've seen the world and unique ways
and I think it's really important to pay
attention to that so you know rather
than continues education when he was
young he ended up going and supporting
his mother financially after his father
died and so he was working as a busboy
and he was also slinging cannabis heroin
on the streets and that's what it was
that you know that's at least what I got
from Wikipedia you know he might be able
to tell you differently about things who
knows or maybe that's from a criminal
report when he got caught but so there
is there's this thing called scum which
is society can't understand me which I
think's and it's kind of a it's a way of
saying that it's difficult for society
to understand people when young people
are trying to find ways to fit into
society that are unconventional that
this whole path that's been paved for a
majority of people in the world doesn't
fit certain people and I think that's
becoming more and more important to
actually realize that at that path
that's paid for so many people is not
the path for everyone in that letting
people go and through these different
creative pursuits and endeavors will
actually unleash their full potential
without putting other people at
SuperDuper danger you know that's really
important as well along the way so
alright just uh you know I don't want to
spend an extreme amount of time on this
stuff but he's extremely complicated
he's
nuanced and he's both he's young and
he's ambitious and He is calling society
out on some [ __ ] but also he is he's not
necessarily listening what society is
trying to tell him in some ways that
could help him he might actually be able
to amplify his impact into civilization
more if he was willing to listen a tiny
little bit more into what society is
trying to say about making sure that
other people are safe so yeah there were
a lot of you know apparently a lot of
chances that were given to him to be
able to to fully realize that himself
that he needs to make sure that other
people feel safe so it's tough because
other people also need to feel some
pressure in their lives and that
pressure is to make the world a better
place and so if you need to put pressure
on two people to you know change their
their greed or their corruption then we
got to do that and that's an important
thing for us to do so yeah there's
there's a lot I think if he had a
serious mentor in his life that could
really help him out I think that would
be very very very helpful and I think
there's a lot of of young people that
need a mentor like that in their life
and with a mentor like that so much can
be achieved because it can take the
wisdom can be disseminated but not
trapping their spirits very complicated
you can't trap their spirit so they
can't flourish but it's more like
helping them augment their vision so
they can flourish in a way that is more
effective because Society has a lot of
many in many ways their constraints but
their constraints for people to be for
people to be safe enough you like their
around gun violence or around extreme
cases of a very addictive drug use that
kind of stuff so I would definitely keep
an eye on what's going on I think he's I
think this aspect to him is very
interesting he has this he has this you
know I'm gonna show you here he has this
very very interesting sort of
personality and style that he carries
with him that you know this style of
like rainbow hair and and a rainbow
clothing and that with that sort of of
like uniqueness that he carries in that
sense that he's getting even more under
people's skin because you know how can
someone dresses that way or looks that
way get under people's skin and like
that's one of the sins that he that he
keeps up on is that he creates the music
that gets tons of streams he creates the
the beef they get some more media and
that he is able to scale up the fastest
and I think this is another thing that
we'll talk about soon and more of our
content about network effects and Los
Angeles is having a major epicenter of
network effects that are that are
bubbling and breeding commingling and
yeah so I just want to say that this is
an extremely New Orleans conversation I
appreciate everyone for for tuning in
and injecting this out and I want to say
that you know don't get caught in the
binary trap get into some nuanced
conversations with people you love about
how to maximize the potential of
Generation Z kids and even younger the
kids being born today that are zero two
four six years old that how do we
maximize their potential into the world
and how do we design an architect
civilization to do so so let's do that
together everyone as we always say on
the show much love go manifest your
destiny into the world build the future
give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you thanks
for tuning in much love and we'll see
you soon peace